ski joe dengash
so as uh with number four speed
getting guys we start in the
to my position kamaya just means ready
position
the hand is on
just above the hip there
not further back and it
it never passes it never passes back
these skis never pass the back
so what you do is you
go forward that doesn't go back
again as in my first film
you do not go backwards to go forwards
in other words do not cover the same
ground twice
just to end up in the same place if so
you've done an action like that
while the other person is not moved so
that means
there's a gap where they can be faster
than you
all right pros and cons
this is easy to do but it's wrong
because i'm going
from here to here just to go back to
here
i'll pass through it yes but look here
okay for a ski journey we
thrash to the this is to stop the heart
so we thrust here
not here remember the v
the hand is on the back
two finger first two fingers again
is what's holding firmly first two
fingers
firmly fingers not
on the joe but tucked away
[Music]
so
so i always break this one down and do
the block and then as you get better and
faster
you still have the block in tension and
feeling
but the hand slides down the jar
and slides down the jar and slides down
the jar
i'm just gonna remove the camera a
little bit for this one
just so you can see this matter since
it's a strike
practice practice and more practice will
make these hands flow
body timing is everything
to break it down
ski
lock and step
just before the end of the block the
hand slides
down
the left hand throws the joe to the back
throws the joe to the back
block left hand throws joe to the back
right hand slides down
you have a quick change of hands in the
middle
remember the hands are here not here
again it's not a two or three stage
thing
if it is a two or three stage thing it's
to show you the points of where you must
be strong
must be strong here must be strong here
for a block
here another stuff so it's my front foot
is open
like the the get in guys
so i naturally have a foot open a lot
so
speed comes through everything being
correct and
you're having body timing don't
everybody wants to go fast but please
let it come naturally
since he said speed will come naturally
the technique is strong you don't have
to be
so get the technique
please watch how the feet float
[Music]
so
just like the get in gosh
my hips are coming through that makes
the strike more powerful please
try to watch the hips i'll come close to
the camera so you can see
just tip the cam on this one down a
little so you can
see the hips
so
everything comes from the hips the power
the hips
you need timing
with the get engaged i forgot to mention
step forward the person's there
people who go round
aren't advancing they just go round
there's no advantage
but you just go around
the other party you've got to go forward
[Music]
so forward forward notice the foot
forward notice the foot on this
judding gosh
it's forward the person is always
in front of you so you want to go
forward
don't don't bounce
another fault that comes a lot
you'll notice my head's a little this
way
not dead straight that's because i'm
getting a lot of power from my hips
but the lower the grade the straighter
you should be
become
yeah very straight the cytosensor used
to be really straight
i'm a little turned i'm not not then yet
okay thank you for your time now the
first
five of the 20 joe don't worry mustard